Now that we know a
little bit about lists,
I thought I would use this
video to introduce you
to loops, and in
particular for loops.
And if we have time, we might
do other types of loops.
But before we even
do that, I want
to introduce you to a built-in
Python function called Ranger.
When I say built-in, it
means it comes with Python.
And it's really
a way to generate
lists that have
integers that increment.
So for example, if I
just say, range of 6,
it generates a list
from 0 through 5.
So it's 6 elements up
to, but not including, 6.
If I wanted to include 6, I
would have to do range of 7.
And then I go all the way
up to, but not including 7.
But I get 6 in there.
If I want to have
1 through 6, if I
don't want to have that 0 there,
I could do range starting at 1
and including 1, up to,
but not including 7.
So the first item
here will be included.
The last item will
not be included.
And there we go.
We get 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
And what's cool about these
integrated development
environments, these IDE's, this
pie scripter that I'm running,
is that, when I type in a
function that it recognizes,
it actually will
tell me a little bit
something about that function,
in case you forget it.
So I don't know if you
can read this here,
but it says, range,
start, stop, step.
So right now, the default is
to increment by 1 each time.
But it says, hey,
I could tell you
to increment by a
different number.
So let's say you have a range.
Say you start at 0, and
you want to go up to 8.
And I want to go up
by 2, instead of 1.
So then I went to 0, 2, 4,
6-- I should have said it more
precisely-- up to,
but not including 8.
The upper part of the
range, you don't include it.
So it goes up to that,
and it increments it by 2.
So you could do it like that.
So maybe you want to start at
3, and you want to go up to,
but not including--
I don't know.
Let me do up to, but
not including 31.
And you want to go
up by steps of 3.
So there you go.
It went up steps by 3, up
to, but not including 31.
So it can generate a
whole bunch of lists.
And the reason
why this is useful
is because we can use
these inside of loops.
And so the first type of loop
I'm going to introduce you to
is a for loop.
So this was the
interpreter down here.
Here, I'm going to
actually write a program.
So this program is really just
to show you a for loop does.
So I could say, for i-- and i
is this variable that's often
used in for loops,
in iterative loops.
And iterative means you keep
doing something over and over
again-- for i in--
and let me just
do a simple one-- in
range-- and I'm just
going to say 5-- range of 5.
So this will generate
a list, 0, 1, 2, 3, 4.
So for i in range 5.
And this colon says,
now we're going
to have a sub clause of what to
do on each of those iterations.
Let's just print out what i is.
And so, before we even see
what this is going to do,
let's just think about it.
It's saying, for each time
we go through this loop,
for each of the things in the
range, make i refer to them.
And then each of those loops is
going to refer a different one.
And you want to print it out.
So let's just try this out.
So let me save this program.
And now, let me run it.
So there you go.
What it did is it
created a loop.
So each time it
goes to the loop,
it assigns i to a different
element in this list.
As you remember, this
list was 0, 1, 2, 3 and 4.
Did I say 0, 1,
2, 3, 4, 5 before?
No, it's 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, up
to, but not including 5.
And so, each time you
go through the loop,
it goes through
each of those items.
And this program really
just says, print out that i.
So the first time we
go to the loop, i is 0.
So it prints it out.
Then it prints out 1.
Then it prints a 2.
Then it prints a 3.
Then it prints a 4.
So it just keeps going
through it that many times.
If we said this
was for range 10.
Now let's run this
program, you'll
see it'll print 1 through 9.
I should say 0 through
9, because that's
the first element in this list.
But you could do more
interesting things.
Let's say that you wanted to
take the sum of 0 through 9.
So what you could do is you
could define another variable
here, sum.
So before I do anything, the
sum is just going to be 0.
And then what you could
say is, each time you go
through the loop, why
don't you define sum
to be the previous sum plus what
i is in this part of the loop?
And just so that we
can keep track of it,
I then want to print the sum.
Now let's see what
this thing does.
So let's try it out.
So let me save it, and
then let me run it.
So there you go.
So the first time we went
to the loop, sum is zero.
Sum is 0 and i is 0.
You add them together.
You print the sum, you get 0.
The next time we go
through the loop, i is 1.
We add that to the previous
sum, which was 0, print it,
you get one.
Then the next time through the
loop, i is now going to be 2.
Add that to the previous
sum, 2 plus 1, you get 3.
Next time through
the loop, i is 3.
You add that to the
previous sum, you get 6.
So the sum of all the
numbers, 0 through 9, is 45.
So just that, that's actually
a kind of a useful program.
But just to make the point
a little bit clearer,
let me actually walk you through
this on my little drawing
tablet.
So let me close my-- let me
paste my code that I just
wrote up here.
And let's just think
about what this is doing.
So we have a couple
of variables here.
We start off with this
variable sum that is set to 0.
And there's two ways
to visualize variables.
A common way to
visualize it-- and this
isn't necessarily wrong, this
is sometimes an easier way
to think about it-- is
to view them as buckets.
But in Python, the really
correct way-- and you
saw why that's
important with lists--
is to view them as
referring to something.
So if you view them as
buckets, you can say, OK,
from the get go, the number
in the sum bucket is 0.
But the reality is, is that
the variable sum is now
referring to the numeric
literal, the actual number 0,
sitting in memory someplace.
Now we enter into the for loop.
And what the for loop
says is, let's iteratively
assign i to each of the
elements in the list generated
by a range of 10.
So just to be clear, if we
called this right over here,
range of 10, this will generate
a list that looks like this.
So it will generate a list 0, 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, and 9, up
to, but not including 10.
This is 10 elements
right over here.
And then we go
into the for loop.
So the first time we go
through the for loop--
and let me write it--
so I'll think about it
two different ways.
So one, I'll think about
it in the bucket way.
So we have this variable,
i, that can actually only
be used inside of this clause.
We'll talk more about scope or
where a variable can be used.
But this i variable is only
good inside of this clause.
The sum variable, the
way I've defined it,
I can use it anywhere, outside
of the clause, or inside of it,
because it was defined
outside of the clause.
So you have your i.
So this is if you think
of it as a bucket.
And so, through the
first iteration,
i is assigned to this
first item over here.
So i is going to be 0.
The better way to
think about it is i
is actually referring to this
first element, our first time
through the loop.
And then we go through the
loop, and it says sum plus i.
Well, sum is 0.
And i is 0.
You add them
together, you get 0.
So sum is still going to be
0, or still referring to 0.
And then it prints the sum out.
So then this line right
over here prints sum.
It says, OK, the sum
right now is just-- let
me do it in blue-- it's just 0.
And it printed it out.
Then it goes back
to the for loop
and says, look, are
there any more elements
that I can assign i to?
Well, sure there are.
There's all of these that
we have to go through.
So then it makes i the next
element in the sequence.
So now i is going to be the
next element in the sequence.
Or another way to think
about it is in the i bucket--
if you want to view
them as buckets--
i is now set equal to 1.
And now we run this again.
And we say, OK, sum is 0 plus i.
I is 1.
So sum is now going
to refer to 1.
Or another way to
think about it is sum
is now going to refer to 1.
And when you print
sum, it'll now print 1.
Then, the for loop
will say, alright,
are there any more elements
in this list right over here
to assign i to?
Well, sure there are.
There's all of these others,
so let me keep going.
So i can now be equal
to, or can refer to, 2.
So if you think of it
as a bucket, i is now 2.
Or you could say, i
is now referring to 2.
And you could ignore
these right over here.
And we go through
the loop again.
Sum is now 1.
1 plus i, i is now 2.
1 plus 2 is 3.
So sum is now going to be 3
this time through the loop.
So sum is now referring to 3.
You print sum, you get 3.
And you keep going all the way.
As we go through
the loop, the loop
will still keep
going, as there's
more things that i can refer to.
We can keep incrementing i to
these other values over here.
And eventually, i
is going to be 9.
We're going to evaluate this.
And the for loop
says, hey, is there
anything left in this
list that i can be?
And you're like, no, there isn't
anything left in this list.
And then the loop
is going to be done.
And we'll break out to it.
And the program will stop.
And that's exactly
what we saw happening,
when we ran the
program over here.